digamos que tengo 40 años 40 años
estoy casada y tengo dos hijos tengo dos
hijos y digamos también que soy la
principal fuente de ingresos de mi
familia y además tenemos una hipoteca
una hipoteca y yo confío en que mis
hijos vayan a la universidad y espero
poder pagar por su universidad
universidad y también quiero asegurarme
que si me sucede cualquier cosa mi
pareja pueda tener un retiro ya que a lo
mejor mi pareja no tiene las habilidades
para poder tener algún ingreso o incluso
aunque lo tenga es muy probable que
tenga que hacerse cargo de los niños y
no pueda dedicarse a tener un ingreso y
debido a todas estas cosas de kim quiero
asegurarme de tener dinero para pagar
todo esto en el evento de mi
fallecimiento por lo que estoy viendo
contratar un seguro de vida seguro de
vida
y creo que la mayoría de nosotros
entiende la idea general de lo que
consiste un seguro de vida se paga
cierta cantidad periódicamente y en el
evento del fallecimiento de uno de
nuestros beneficiarios quienquiera que
nosotros hayamos puesto como
beneficiarios del seguro en caso de
nuestra muerte esas personas recibirán
algún dinero aunque un seguro de vida no
es tan sencillo o bueno hay una versión
del seguro de vida que si es sencilla y
otra que no lo es por lo que tenemos dos
tipos de seguros de vida el seguro de
vida a plazos y el seguro de vida
completo seguro a plazos y seguro
completo hablamos del seguro a plazos
porque es más sencillo francamente voy a
mi compañía de seguros y ellos me dicen
mira si tú pagas una prima de 500
dólares al año si se paga una prima cada
año de 500 dólares
esa palabra prima significa la cantidad
de dinero que se tiene que pagar cada
año si se paga una prima de 500 dólares
cada año durante 10 años así que nos ha
periodo aquí es de 10 años periodo 10
años
si uno falleciera en cualquier punto
durante estos diez años se recibiría o
recibirían los beneficiarios 500 mil
dólares eso es lo que recibirían los
beneficiarios que indicamos en este
seguro de vida 500 mil dólares
recordemos que los beneficiarios son
obviamente las personas que reciben el
beneficio de la póliza de seguro de vida
quienes van a recibir el pago en caso de
fallecimiento por esta póliza así que
durante los siguientes 10 años se
pagarán 500 dólares y en caso de
fallecimiento su familia beneficiarios
recibirán 500 mil dólares y la razón por
la que esto le funciona a la compañía de
seguros es que ellos calculan bueno si
no son fumadores si tienen buena salud
es poco probable que vayan a fallecer en
los siguientes 10 años
promedian esto entre muchos miles de
personas van a obtener dinero algunas
personas aleatoriamente fallecerán pero
van a recibir la prima de todos los
demás que es más que suficiente para
hacer el pago de aquellos que fallezca
ya sea en accidentes o por alguna
enfermedad repentina la razón por la que
se llama seguro por periodo es que si
uno no fallece en estos diez años se
tendrá que contratar otra nueva póliza
de seguro ustedes contratan su póliza de
seguro hacen sus pagos pasan diez años
no sucede nada ustedes siguen viviendo y
todo este dinero que pagaron en las
primas pues podríamos decir que se
pierde ustedes les dieron esas primas a
la compañía de seguros para que les
pagara a sus beneficiarios esta cantidad
en caso de su fallecimiento pero no
ocurrió nada todo está bien en este
ejemplo quizás esta sea una buena opción
ya que si ustedes tienen 40 años
probablemente es la edad en la que sus
hijos ya comiencen ir a la universidad
eso les da el tiempo para ahorrar más
dinero para el retiro también para pagar
más a su hipoteca y para ahorrar para el
colegio o la universidad
bueno diez años me parece adecuado para
mí y ustedes tienen cuarenta años y
quiero más tiempo para pagar la hipoteca
ahorrar dinero para la universidad
ahorrar dinero para el retiro por lo que
quieren contratar una póliza a veinte
años podemos contratar una póliza a
veinte años y en el caso de que sea una
póliza de veinte años la prima va a ser
un poquito más alta y la razón por la
que esta prima va a ser un poco más alta
es que aumenta la probabilidad de
fallecer en 20 años en las edades de 50
a 60 años es más probable fallecer que
de 40 a 50 años las compañías de seguros
tomando en cuenta estas probabilidades y
es por eso que las primas de pago anual
son un poco mayores pero de cualquier
manera que se vea en una póliza a plazo
o por periodo se paga una prima fija
durante un periodo fijo si se fallece
durante ese periodo los familiares
recibirán el beneficio de esta póliza en
caso de no vaya a ser la póliza
simplemente va a expirar y se tendrá que
contratar otra póliza de seguro de vida
en otra situación donde ustedes tengan
70 años de edad y siguen vivos
que eso esperemos que ocurra es muy
difícil obtener una póliza de seguro a
plazo o por periodo ya que las compañías
de seguros saben que la probabilidad de
fallecer en los siguientes diez años
cuando uno tiene 70 años son muy altas y
por eso las aseguradoras no toman el
riesgo este tipo de seguros de vida son
muy buenos cuando ustedes son más o
menos jóvenes y quieren tener más tiempo
para ahorrar y cubrir todas estas
obligaciones y si algo les ocurriera
entonces su familia podría aprovechar lo
que les dé el seguro para cubrir esas
obligaciones y eso es lo que yo tengo
como seguro de vida tengo un seguro de
vida a plazo porque ahorita tengo 34
años digo no estoy tan grande y tengo
una hipoteca y tengo un hijo pequeño y
quiero asegurarme de que si cualquier
cosa me sucede mi familia el plazo de mi
póliza es de 20 años así que si algo me
llegara a pasar a mí en estos 20 años mi
familia estaría cubierta y recibiría
este dinero de la póliza para que no
quede desamparada el otro tipo de seguro
es el seguro de vida completo la
motivación para este tipo de pólizas de
seguro viene
y de que las personas no les gusta esta
noción de que se paga dinero en una
póliza de seguro a plazos año tras año y
al no ofrecer que es algo bueno pero si
no fallecen pues todo ese dinero se
perdió no se los devuelven o los
ahorraron ese dinero se perdió y el otro
problema es que la póliza de seguro a
plazo es válido durante solo cierto
período de diez años veinte años lo que
sea algunas personas les gusta la idea
de querer conservar una prima durante
toda su vida y cuando fallezcan que
hasta donde sabemos todos nosotros algún
día hemos de morir cuando se fallezca la
familia recibirá los beneficios a lo
mejor ahorita que tengo 40 años voy a
estar pagando esta prima durante otros
40 años y a lo mejor falleció a los 80
años y en ese momento mi familia va a
recibir algo de todo ese seguro que ha
estado pagando durante 40 años así que
el seguro de vida completo es para
atraer a esas personas que les interesa
esta idea pero las compañías de seguro
no son tontas al contrario ellos
dicen muy bien toda esta situación y se
aseguran de ello recibir alguna ganancia
así que lo que ellos hacen en una póliza
de seguro de vida completa es que
aumentan el costo de la prima de manera
que tienen los beneficios de la póliza
de seguros a plazos más una sección en
donde pueden ahorrar pero les cobran
bastante por eso de manera que le
resulta un buen negocio a las compañías
de seguros así que la póliza de seguro
de vida completo para una persona de 40
años y aquí no voy a estar inventando
números la prima y digamos que la póliza
es de también 500 mil dólares así que la
prima en esa situación podría ser mucho
más alta que en la de plazos podrían ser
cinco mil dólares cinco mil dólares por
año y el plazo pues es toda su vida por
lo tanto no hay un plazo ni siquiera
debo describir esto ya que en el nombre
está implícito que es todo el tiempo de
vida y en cualquier momento que ustedes
lleguen a fallecer mientras hayan pagado
la prima puntual
en el momento en el que ustedes fallecen
su familia va a recibir el beneficio de
la póliza
que desde 500 mil dólares al momento de
la muerte ya lo mejor ustedes ven que
esto es un abuso el pagar 10 veces más
en primas por la misma cantidad de
asegurada y hay un par de cosas que hay
que considerar ya que no es tanto el
abuso aunque siempre va a ser más caro
que la póliza de seguro a plazos es que
esto siempre y cuando continuamos
pagando las primas puntualmente esto es
algo garantizado algún día vamos a
fallecer por lo que esa es una cantidad
de asegurada en cambio en el caso de la
póliza a plazos cuando uno tiene 60 o 70
años las compañías de seguro van a
cobrar una prima todavía mucho más cara
para asegurarnos por esta cantidad ya
que piensan que hay una gran
probabilidad de que se fallezca en el
plazo de esta póliza en el de vida
completa se paga la misma prima aunque
es bastante cara cuando uno es bastante
joven esta prima base definitivamente
más grande que la prima del seguro de
vida a plazos pero cuando uno llega a
los 70 años y pregunta por una póliza de
seguro a plazos
a lo mejor ni siquiera podemos obtener y
en caso de que podamos conseguirla la
prima va a ser tremendamente cara no sé
quizás diez mil dólares al año y en ese
punto de la vida esta opción será más
barata otra cosa que hace este tipo de
póliza
completa la compañía de seguros
implícitamente va a apartar una parte de
este dinero para asegurar nuestra vida y
va a apartar otra sección para tenerla
como efectivo y ese efectivo va a crecer
durante el tiempo no toda nuestra prima
va en esta parte del efectivo pero una
parte si lo hace los primeros años casi
la prima completa va hacia la compañía
de seguros y a partir de ahí cada año
una fracción de esta prima va a ir a
esta sección del efectivo una sección de
ahorros dentro de la póliza de seguros
vamos a escribir los ahorros de efectivo
y esto puede tener intereses puede
obtener intereses mientras se encuentre
en la compañía de seguros así que a lo
mejor alguien que les quiera vender un
seguro de vida completo les puede decir
oye esto es algo muy bueno pagar a la
prima se garantiza esta prima durante
toda su vida sus beneficiarios recibirán
esta cantidad siempre y cuando se paguen
estas primas y además le estamos creando
esta cuenta de ahorros para usted quizás
en algún punto ustedes digan bueno estos
riesgos ya no los tengo no quiero seguir
pagando esta prima a lo mejor tienen 65
años ya pagaron su hipoteca ahorraron
mucho dinero y dice bueno voy a dejar de
pagar esa prima así que bueno esto nos
olvidamos de esto pero se puede obtener
lo que está en su cuenta de ahorros ese
dinero en efectivo y sus intereses los
pueden sacar algo que no dicen las
compañías de seguro es que aunque
parezca que tenemos nuestro seguro de
vida y también una cuenta de ahorros lo
que quizás no clarifiquen es que hay
muchas cuotas en esta cuenta de ahorros
por lo que definitivamente es una mejor
opción
y eso es lo que buscan ustedes de
guardar o ahorrar algo y aún así tener
un seguro de vida durante un periodo
fijo de tiempo para que puedan terminar
con esas obligaciones probablemente una
mejor opción sería que contratarán el
seguro de vida a plazo pagar esta prima
más barata si ésta fuera una cantidad
real que bueno son cantidades que yo
inventé pero la diferencia entre estas
dos primas es de cuatro mil quinientos
dólares así que puedo yo tomar esa
diferencia y ahorrar los o invertirlos
durante el período que dure esta póliza
seguramente obtendremos mucho más dinero
y más intereses haciendo esto porque no
estaremos pagando todas las cuotas que
están asociadas con la cuenta de ahorros
del seguro